In this web security course you will learn
all about dev SEC ops from me Beau Carnes,
you will learn how to take advantage of common web
vulnerabilities, how to fix those vulnerabilities
and how to use DedSec ops tools to make sure
your applications are secure. For the end,
Eric Smalling from sneek will talk about securing
containers and more about dev SEC ops. Soon I'll
be showing you how to implement common hacking
techniques. But first I'll give an overview of DEV
SEC ops. Dev SEC ops refers to the integration of
security practices into a DevOps software delivery
model. In a dev SEC ops model, security objectives
are integrated as early as possible in the
lifecycle of software development, and security
considerations are important throughout the
lifecycle. Later, I'll be going into more details
about what this actually means in practice.
But first, to really understand dev SEC ops, it
can be helpful to first understand DevOps and also
vulnerabilities. Thanks to sneek for sponsoring
this course, their resources made this possible.
Let's start with vulnerabilities. The whole point
of security is to protect against vulnerabilities.
So let's understand the different types. And
afterwards, I'll discuss DevOps, the average
cost of a data breach in 2020 was $3.86 million
in global cybercrime costs are expected to reach
$6 trillion. By the end of this year, it
is estimated that 90% of web applications
are vulnerable to hacking, and 68% of those
are vulnerable to the breach of sensitive data.
In 2020, there were over 1000 data breaches in
the United States, according to the identity theft
Resource Center, and over 155 point 8 million
individuals were affected by data exposures.
When thinking about security, it is important to
understand the difference between a vulnerability
an exploit and a threat a security vulnerability
is a software code flaw or a system
misconfiguration that hackers can use to gain
unauthorized access to a system or network. Once
inside, the attackers can leverage authorizations
and privileges to compromise systems and assets.
An exploit is the method hackers used to exploit
a vulnerability and exploit is typically a piece
of custom software, or a sequence of
commands. There are even exploit kits
that can be embedded in compromised web pages,
where they continuously scan for vulnerabilities.
As soon as a weakness is detected. That kid
immediately attempts to deploy an exploit,
such as injecting malware into the host system.
A threat is the actual or hypothetical event in
which one or more exploits use a vulnerability
to mount an attack, only a small amount of
known vulnerabilities will be used to hack into a
system vulnerabilities that pose the highest risk
or those that have a higher chance of being
exploited, and therefore should be the ones that
are prioritized. security vulnerabilities can be
found in all different areas related to software.
Here are some common security vulnerabilities
in applications and websites. There are two
different important lists of weaknesses and
web applications. The first list is created
by the Open Web Application Security Project or
OWASP. They have a popular list called the OWASP
Top 10 that features the most commonly exploited
vulnerabilities. The second list is CW IE or
common weakness, enumeration, which is a community
developed list of common software and hardware
weakness types that have security ramifications.
This list is run by the MIT or E or MITRE
Corporation, which is a not for profit company
that operates federal government funded r&d
centers. They create the CW e 25, which is their
list of the 25 most dangerous software weaknesses
in the CW e 25. There are three major types of
application and website security weaknesses.
There's porous defenses, risky resource management
and insecure interaction between components
see porous defenses weakness is one that could
allow users to bypass or spoof authentication and
authorization processes. Authentication verifies
the identity of someone trying to access a system
well authorization is the set of access and usage
permissions assigned to the user. Porous defense
weakness examples include weak password encoding,
insufficiently protected credentials, missing or
single factor authentication. insecurely
inherited permissions or sessions that don't
expire in a timely manner. All of these porous
defense vulnerability types can allow hackers to
successfully access sensitive resources exploits
that leverage these vulnerabilities may include
credential stuffing attacks, hijacking of session
IDs, stealing login credentials, or man in the
middle attacks. The next vulnerable category
is risky management of resources such as memory
functions and open source frameworks. The types
of vulnerabilities in this category are out of
bound read or write, which is the same as buffer
overflow. The application can be tricked into
writing or reading data past the end or before
the beginning of the intended memory buffer.
Also path traversal This allows attackers to get
to path names that let them access files out of
restricted directories. I'll be showing an example
of this later. exploiting these vulnerabilities
allow hackers to gain control over an
application or damaged files or even access
sensitive information. And then the final major
weakness area is insecure interaction between
components. Many applications today send and
receive data across a wide range of services,
threads and processes. The way different
components interact with with each other can
introduce vulnerabilities. weaknesses that expose
a web application or website in this manner,
can include cross site scripting. This is
when user inputs are not handled securely,
it can open up the possibility for cross site
scripting attacks that enable attackers to inject
client side scripts into web pages viewed by
other users. This is a very common vulnerability.
There's also cross site request forgery. This
is improper verification of whether a seemingly
legitimate and authentic request was intentionally
sent. These attacks are often mountain via social
engineering vectors such as bogus emails that
trick a user to click a link, which then sends
a forged request to a site or server where the
user has already been authenticated. If apps
and websites don't properly implement security
controls for interaction between components,
this leaves them vulnerable to backdoor attacks,
scripting attacks, worms, Trojan horses, and
other exploits that deploy malicious code to wreak
havoc on infrastructure data and systems between
the OSI 10 and CW e 25. Lists, it is clear that
broken access control is the top vulnerability
94% of applications have some sort of
broken access control, access control,
make sure that users cannot act outside of their
intended permissions. So if this is not set up
properly, it can lead to unauthorized information
disclosure, or modification or even destruction
of data. Now let's talk about DevOps, which is an
important part of DEV SEC ops. DevOps is a concept
that has been talked about and written about for
a long time, and many definitions of DevOps have
emerged. DevOps is basically a set of practices
that combined software development, the dev
and IT operations, the ops, it aims to
shorten the systems development lifecycle,
and provides continuous delivery with high
software availability. So you can see in the
DevOps pipeline, it basically goes on infinitely
going through all these different steps.
Most modern DevOps organizations will depend on
some combination of continuous integration and
continuous deployment or delivery systems in
the form of a CI CD pipeline. As part of the
lifecycle, a variety of automated security testing
and validation can be performed without requiring
the manual work of a human operator. And this is
all part of the software development lifecycle.
Here's an example of a common DevOps flow.
First, a developer will write code and push it to
a repo. At that point, the CI CD pipeline starts.
There are automated tests, then a version is built
that's eventually deployed to production. There
are tests every step to assure code quality,
but in this module, security is sometimes only
considered right before deploying to production.
DedSec ops follows a similar flow, but adds
automated security considerations throughout
the process. Security is integrated with the
DevOps, that sac ops codifies security objectives
as part of the overall goal structure. This shield
represents all the places we test for security.
Different tools are used for different steps. And
I'll talk some about the specific tools later.
Def SEC ops should be thought of as
the natural continuation of DevOps,
rather than as a separate idea or concept.
activities designed to identify and ideally
solve security issues are injected early in
the lifecycle of application development,
rather than after a product is released. This
is accomplished by enabling development teams to
perform many of the security tasks independently
within the software development lifecycle.
To integrate security objectives early in the
development of an application, start before
the first line of code is ever written. Security
can integrate and begin effective Threat Modeling
during the initial concept of the system,
application or even individual user story,
a static analysis linters and policy engines
can be run anytime a developer checks in code,
ensuring that any low hanging fruit is dealt
with before the changes move further upstream.
Later, I'll be showing you how to use a
tool to check code for security issues.
While you're writing it. Software composition
analysis can be applied to confirm that any
open source dependencies have compatible
licenses, and are free of vulnerabilities.
I'll be showing you how to use a tool to check
software dependencies for security issues.
It can be very helpful to get immediate
feedback on the relative security of the
code you've written. And this helps individual
developers take ownership of security issues.
Once code is checked in static application,
security testing or SAS tools can be used to
identify vulnerabilities and performed software
composition analysis. SAS tools should be
integrated into post commit processes to ensure
that new code introduced is proactively scanned
for vulnerabilities. Having a SAS tool integration
in place enables remediation of vulnerabilities
early in the software development lifecycle,
and it reduces application risk and exposure.
After the code builds, you can start to employ
security integration tests. Running the code in
an isolated container sandbox allows for automated
testing of things like network calls input
validation and authorization. These tests are
often part of dynamic application scanning tools,
or deste. These tests generate fast feedback,
enabling quick iteration and triage of any issues
that are identified, causing minimal disruption
to the overall stream. If things like unexplained
network calls or unsanitized input occur,
the tests fail and the pipeline generates
actionable feedback in the form of reporting
and notifications to the relevant teams.
Next to things like correct logging
and access controls can be tested.
Does the application log relevant security and
performance metrics correctly, is access limited
to the correct subset of individuals or even
prevented entirely. Finally, the application makes
its way to production. But security tests continue
automated patching and configuration management
ensure the production environment is always
running the latest and most secure versions
of software dependencies. special techniques
and tools can be used to secure containers.
Later, you will learn how to do
this in a real world environment.
Using a dev SEC ops or CI CD pipeline helps
integrate security objectives at each phase,
allowing the rapid delivery to be maintained. The
entire approach helps minimize vulnerabilities
that reduce production, thereby reducing the cost
associated with fixing security flaws. Dev SEC
ops aims to build security into every stage of
the delivery process and establish a plan for
security automation. When thinking about security,
you should remember that your code is just the tip
of the iceberg. In an average software project,
only 10 to 20% of code is custom code. Yes,
it is important to make sure your custom code
is secure. But there's a lot more to think
about 80 to 90% of mini code bases consists
of open source code modules and libraries.
The frameworks and libraries that you import can
themselves import more frameworks and libraries.
This is code that you didn't actually
write yourself, you know, on average,
80% of vulnerabilities are found in direct
dependencies. It doesn't matter how good you are
at writing secure code. If you import vulnerable
dependencies, then there are containers. These
often consist of hundreds of Linux packages
inherited from public sources, again,
code that you didn't actually write yourself
and you can't forget about infrastructures code.
This opens up a bunch of new attack vectors for
malicious actors. misconfiguration is the number
one cloud vulnerability. Dev SEC ops properly
implemented should cover all of these areas. So
it should be becoming obvious. But let's talk more
about why def SEC ops practices are important.
As companies get larger, there's often
more software cloud technologies and
DevOps methodologies. More software means more
of the organization's risk becomes digital,
making it increasingly challenging to secure
digital assets. Cloud technologies means that
many of the IT and infrastructure risks are
moved to the cloud. This raises the importance of
permission and access management, since
everything can be accessed from anywhere.
As you've seen dev SEC ops bring security into
DevOps, enabling development teams to secure
what they build at their pace, while
also creating greater collaboration
between development and security practitioners.
Security Teams offer expertise and tooling to
increase developer autonomy while still providing
a level of oversight. So here are six benefits
of the dev SEC ops model. Compared to the
traditional DevOps model. faster delivery,
the speed of software delivery is improved
when security is integrated in the pipeline.
Bugs are identified and fixed before deployment,
allowing developers to focus on shipping features
improve security posture. Security is a
feature from the design phase onwards, a shared
responsibility model ensures security is tightly
integrated from building deploying to securing
production workloads, reduce costs, identifying
vulnerabilities and bugs before deploying
results, and an exponential reduction in risk and
operational costs, enhancing the value of DevOps.
improving overall security posture as a
culture of shared responsibility is created
by the integration of security practices into
DevOps. Improving security, integration and pace,
cost and time of secure software delivery is
reduced through eliminating the need to retrofit
security controls, post development, enabling
greater overall business success, greater trust
in the security of develop software, and embracing
new technologies enables enhanced revenue growth,
and expanded business offerings. It's about to get
practical, I'm going to show you how to exploit
some common web app vulnerabilities. And I'm
going to show you how to use dev SEC ops tools
to make sure your software is secure. We're going
to learn some hacking techniques, as well as learn
how to prevent hacking. By using this goofy
app. This was developed by sneek. And it's
a vulnerable demo app, it was created with some
common vulnerabilities. So we can learn how to
hack those vulnerabilities. And also even
better how to fix those vulnerabilities.
So the whole goal is to make sure the apps that
you develop do not have vulnerabilities. But we
can also use it to figure out how to check for
check vulnerabilities and other programs and apps.
So let's download this we're going to I'm going
to copy this. Now I've got my terminal open.
And I'm just going to clone that project. So
git clone, and then I'll paste in the link here.
So after you clone it, there's two ways to get
this running. You can run Mongo on your local
machine like this, and then we already cloned
it, then you can do NPM install and npm start.
There is actually a simpler way to do it, I think,
which is to use Docker Compose, you can use either
method, I'm going to use Docker Compose. So
to install Docker compose you can follow the
instructions on this website for whatever your
operating system is. I'm gonna install on Mac.
Okay, I'm just gonna copy this or you
can just remember this Docker compose
up build. Now you can see I'm in the directory, no
GS goof and then we'll do Docker compose up build
Okay, this looks like is running. Let's check it
on our web browser. I'm going to open up a new tab
and it loads the goof To Do app. And this is
just a simple app. It's not really fulfilling
featured or anything, but it has enough as
part of it, that we can test some hacking
techniques. And then we'll also be able to see
how to fix those and how to secure our app.
So it can't be hacked. So let's just do some
tests. To do let's see, buy milk. Finish tutorial.
Eat ice cream. Okay, well, this To Do app looks
pretty good. Before we start hacking it, I'm going
to actually open up the code for the app. So we
can look at the code. And we'll be going kind of
going back and forth between the actual code used
to develop this app, and the way that we can hack
the app. And then we'll go back to the code and
see how we can fix the things that are vulnerable.
Okay, so just open up the the no GS Gouf
directory in any code editor. I'm using VS code.
And if we go into views, we can see
that it's using the EGS extension.
And then here's the view we're on right now,
where you can create a new item in it's
going to return each of the two dues here.
But you can see there are a few other views here
we have an admin view, account. And then we have
index layout. So we're going to start our hacking
by trying to get into this admin page. So if I go
here and do slash login, we want to figure
out how we can log in to this admin access.
So a hacker will possibly do some sort of social
engineering, or some or maybe just searching on
websites to find out what the admin username is
it could be admin, or in this case, it's admin,
at sneak that IO, because this was developed by
snake.io. So there's a few ways we could try to
figure out how to get into this page. But using a
different tool than just a web browser is going to
be helpful, we could use a command line and use
curl. Or we can do it in a more kind of visual
way. And use something called Burp suite. Burp
suite is is a tool that a lot of penetration
testers and hackers use in Burp suite has a lot
of features that make it easy to test different
things about websites and change things and
really try to hack different parts of websites.
So I'm just going to type in download
Burp suite into Google. And I'm going
to download the free community
edition for my operating system.
Okay, just open up Burp suite for the
first time. And I'm just gonna click
Next to create a temporary project and start burp.
And what we want to do is be able to intercept the
HTTP requests that we're sending to the website
and change them, we want to modify the
requests that are going to the web sites.
And we can do that by going to the target,
you know, going to the proxy tab, intercept.
And now we have intercept is on. But
to actually intercept the things,
we need to intercept the things on a web browser.
It's kind of complicated to set it up to use
our built in web browsers like Google Chrome or
Firefox. But Burp suite has an embedded browser,
that makes it a lot simpler. So we're
going to open up this embedded browser.
And here's the Burp suite embedded browser.
And I'm going to make sure intercept is off
for now. When it's on, you're going to have
to click forward in between each request.
But we will do that later, but not quite yet.
Now I'm just going to get the URL localhost 3001.
And then I'll paste it into the browser. Okay,
great. We can see the website right in the Burp
suite browser. Now I'm going to go over to
slash login. Okay, so we're now there at this
page. I'm going to turn intercept on and
I'll move this over to the side here.
And so we'll use the username we
already know which is admin at sneak
that IO. And then I'll just put anything
for the password and then click Submit. If
we go over here it has actually even though I
click Submit, it hasn't tried to submit it yet.
It it's going to caught this request.
It intercepted the request right here.
So So as you can see it has the username.
It also has the password I was trying to
type wrong, but I spelled it wrong. And we
can now change what sent to the backend,
we can change what values are sent
to the back end. So at this point,
if I just clicked forward, it's just
going to send that those values.
Now, I already said that this wasn't a fully
complete app. So when you log in incorrect,
it doesn't currently have a page that shows you
when you log in and correct. It just says this.
So we know we've logged in incorrectly. If we've
logged if we had logged in to admin correctly,
it would actually go to the admin page. But
we're going to go back to the login page, and
turn intercept off. And then I'm going to type
the in one more time. And I'm just going to type
in a password one more time, I'm going to turn
intercept on, we're going to attempt a no SQL
injection. Now what a hacker would do would
be just to try a bunch of different methods.
And eventually they're going to try a no SQL
injection. So this is the method I'm going
to show you right now. So if we go over here, to
our request, right now, the password is a string,
we're all passing in strings. But what if the
password wasn't a string? What if it was an
object? Could an object actually be harmful or
considered an issue? Well, let's try. If we're
going to be sitting in a JSON object, we're going
to actually have to change this request a bit.
We're going instead of accepting text, there's
not going to be a JSON object. So we're
going to change it to application slash JSON
star slash star q equals 0.5. That's how we're
going to accept JSON objects. And then we're also
going to change the content type. So where's that,
so this is going to become application slash JSON.
Now, we can just pass in instead of this text down
here, we're going to pass in an object, and the
object is going to have the username and password.
Username, it's going to be the same thing
as before. But this time, we have to put
in strings because this is an object. So
this is going to be admin at sneak that IO.
And then we'll have the password.
Remember, we're doing a no SQL injection,
we're not going to pass the string here,
this is going to be an object. And the object is
going to go like this. Let me just type it all in
really quick. This here, in this no SQL injection,
it's passed in as is to the password property,
and it has a specific meaning to MongoDB.
It uses this dollar sign GT operation,
which stands for greater than, so we in essence,
tell MongoDB to match that username with any
record that has a password that is greater
than this empty string, which is bound to hit
a record. So this is a no SQL injection vector.
So let's try this. I'm going to forward this on.
And though afford it one more
time. And now you can see,
we are now in the admin admin access granted,
we're now logged in as admin. We're going to do
a few more of these. And then we're going to go
into the code and see how to fix some of these
problems. So there's another URL on this page,
once you're logged in, called account details.
So since we're logged in, we can
get to the Account Details page.
Oh, let me turn on intercept or turn off
intercept, so it goes to a quicker so we can enter
these account details. I'm just about to show you
a code injection. This is rendered as a handlebars
view. Let's see if you if we go back over to this
code. So this is a this is created in handlebars.
And the same view is used for both the
get request which shows the count details,
as well as the form itself for post
request, which updates the account details.
So it's, it's basically server side rendering.
So the way the forum works is that it receives
the profile information, and then passes it
as is to the template. This means however,
that the attacker is able to control a variable
that flows directly from the request into the
view template library. Now a hacker isn't going
to know all this, but they're going to try a bunch
of things to figure out if it just happens
to maybe have one of these vulnerabilities.
So if you just do like normal,
we can just type in everything.
And it's going to save the account details to the
database. So to do this code injection, instead of
using Burp suite, I'm going to show you how to do
with curl. Okay, I'm just going to paste them this
line here, this is going to use curl to login
to the website using the administrator account,
we have the administrator. And now we actually
are using the real password super secret password.
You could also use some of these other methods,
other methods we showed before to try to hack in
without knowing the password. But in this case,
I'm showing you a different vulnerability. So
we're just going to use the real password, just
don't tell anybody what it is. And we are going
to save this cookie to see that txt, that way
that we can do another curl command and still be
logged in with this administrator cookie. So let
me just hit enter here. Okay, so we're logged in
to the administrator, it says we're redirecting
to slash admin, because I logged in correctly.
Now I'm just going to paste in another curl
command. So you can see the end of this curl
command is the URL we're going to which is
the Account Details page. This is the one
we were just looking at on the web browser, we
are doing a post request, we're not trying to
get the file, we're not trying to get the
page, we're trying to send data to the page.
And we are going to log in using the see that
txt file this was stored on the computer when we
logged in with the administrator here. So we're
still the administrator when we do this action.
And if you see here, this is the information
that's being sent over. So you can see we have
fields for every field on that page, we have
email, first name, last name, country phone.
So those are all these details on here.
But you can see there's one final thing,
there's layout. If we pass layout, when we
pass it to a template language like handlebars,
this could lead to a local file inclusion or path
traversal vulnerability. So let me show you what
happens. You can see what you lay out. And then we
have with path in the file path to get to a file
on the server. So we're going to see if we can
actually get information from the server. And yes,
it's it's returning the package that JSON
file. So you could use the same concept to try
to return the text of any file on the server.
This could include passwords, hash passwords,
or any sort of any sort of data, you may be
able to figure out by using this this hack.
Now let's look at another vulnerability. We're
gonna see this one first right in the code,
and then we'll go and try it out in the browser.
So I'm on the admin view. And if we go down,
we can see that it introduces a redirect page
query path, the redirect page is rendered as
raw HTML and not properly escaped. Because
it uses this dash instead of it should be an
equal sign. So this introduces a
cross site scripting vulnerability.
Let me show you how you would take advantage of
this vulnerability. Okay, so I'm going to go to
the normal login page. And now I'm going to add a
query parameter. It's going to be redirect page.
But instead of adding a normal URL or page that
we're going to, I'm going to add some JavaScript.
And it works, this alert came up. So we've
been able to successfully inject JavaScript
code into this page. Okay, I'm going to show
off one more vulnerability, and then we'll
start looking into how we can find and fix these
vulnerabilities. So I'm at the main to do here.
And I'm just going to try some different things
like let's see if we can add markdown. Hello.
Now that I see like in Markdown, maybe
there's something else I can do. Now,
there's different libraries that can be used to
add markdown like this. In this case, we're using
the marked library. And a hacker may know that
certain libraries have certain vulnerabilities.
But even if they don't know about certain
vulnerabilities, they may just try a bunch
of different things and see what they can figure
out. So let's see if we can make a link appear.
Okay, we can make it show a link right here. In
this case, I supposed to put http colon slash
last, but you can see it still works here. And
now let's see if we can get it to run JavaScript.
Well, that's good, it's not vulnerable
to just typing in JavaScript in there.
There may be something else we could try
though, let's see if we can make another link.
And just put in some JavaScript right in here.
Okay, that's gonna work, which is good. But one
thing that is common is to represent that in a
different way. So So I got the same one
we just typed in. But I'm going to make
a few slight changes, we can actually replace
this colon with the HTML entity for a colon.
So it's going to be like this. And then this final
parentheses we can represent with HTML entity.
So let's test this. Well, it didn't run the
JavaScript, but you can see something different
happened, it doesn't look the same as this. So
we now know that the sanitation is happening
in a different way, when we put these other
symbols here, and like I said, this is using the
open source library markdown, so anybody can just
run, just read through that code. And they may be
able to figure out vulnerabilities just by reading
through the code. So the reason why this isn't
working is because the people who created marked
are actually sanitizing this out and looking for
something like this and removing it. However, we
can actually take advantage of something that a
browser does, a browser actually tries to fix your
JavaScript code. So if it sees something wrong,
it actually tries to figure out, figure out what
you meant. So we can type something like this,
like the actual word, this here. And the browser
is just going to try to try to try to figure out
what this means. But the interesting thing is the
mark library, when it's trying to sanitize things,
it's not trying, it's not looking for this
set of characters, it's only looking for just
this set of characters. So if it seeds, this full
set of characters, it's not going to sanitize,
it's not going to replace it with anything. But
the browser will still build try to figure out
what this means. So let's just put this in here.
And now we have a link, if I click the link,
now it's running the JavaScript code. So we're
able to send JavaScript code that can run right
in someone's browser. And in this To Do app, this
could be something that other people to view the
to do's and you could actually make someone run
JavaScript code. So this is a cross site scripting
vulnerability, right in our application, just
because of this library that we're using. So let's
see if we can go about finding and fixing some of
these vulnerabilities. Let's go back into our code
editor. There's a program called sneak code,
which is a static application security testing
software, or SAST. And there are plugins for
a lot of different IDE s, there's a VS code
plugin that we're going to use right now. So let's
install this plug in, this is going to help us
find our security vulnerabilities and
fix their security vulnerabilities.
So I'm just going to search for sneak.
And I'll just install this once sneak
vulnerability scanner with the 12,000 here.
Okay, now that this is installed, we
can see a new icon here, this sneak icon
is going to work better, we're
going to actually connect it here.
Okay, so I got my account created, and
I'm logged in, and I can authenticate.
So we're already searching the open source
vulnerabilities up here. And then down here,
code scan and quality, we're going to have to
enable it. So click this link, and then enable
and then save changes.
Okay, let me go back over here. And now it's
just it's analyzing the code from this project.
This analysis runs automatically
whenever you open a folder or workplace.
And then also when you save, it's
going to scan the code automatically.
So we can start clicking into these. So these
are our open source dependencies, things that are
different packages we have. And then down here is
the vulnerabilities and our actual custom code.
So I click one of these issues here. And
you can see it's going to go right here is
going to underline it is going to tell you what
the error is. And then it's going to give you
some more information about it. So actually,
let's let's look at this issue in particular
So this is for the login unsanitized input from
the HTTP request body flows and defined where
it is using an SQL query. This may result in
an SQL injection vulnerability. And this was
one of the vulnerabilities that we were able
to take advantage of. So we now know where the
vulnerability is. And it's going to over here,
give us some information about how to fix it.
So it's showing here it's showing some it says
this vulnerability was fixed by 255. Projects,
here are three example fixes. This
is similar code from other projects,
showing what people did to
fix this mistake. So if we go,
we can actually go through these to get
different examples of what people did. What
so we also can get more information about
the vulnerability by clicking here more info.
And we can see it's the the SQL injection
vulnerability. So here, what if the login handler,
it's actually going to take whatever password
the user entered, and then it's going to
this user, that file is going to pass that
everything directly to the back end database for
validation. And it's going to pass the exact text
that the user entered, or in our case, remember,
this is where we pass an object, we were able to
pass an object with the owner with the greater
than, and this allowed us to log into the
administrator account without knowing the password
just by passing in an object. And because this is
just passing in, whatever the user types in into
the database, that's how we were able to do the
SQL injection. It's all because MongoDB uses JSON
to query the database. So it's the SQL injection
where in this case, actually a no SQL injection.
So the very absolute simplest way to solve this
problem would just be to cast this to a string,
the password. So if someone puts in an object,
it will actually when it gets cast to a string,
it will look like this. If you cast an object
to a string, it just looks like Object.
Object, which would not, which would not be
the correct password. There are this is like a
simplest way. But there's much better ways such as
there's different libraries that can help you. And
there's different ways that you can, can make sure
this is not a problem. But this would just be like
the simplest way to make sure someone cannot
pass an object in for the password. So we'll just
ignore that even though there are better ways to
fix that. We're going to ignore that because we're
going to use this, this way to fix this problem.
Not only can you see all your code security issues
by just clicking here, if we actually go to our
file explorer, any file that's red is actually
going to be a file that sneak is found to have
security issues. So we can close that. And we
can see that it's finding security issues in this
file. And these are all things if I click on here
have you problem, it's going to show
right in here, avoid hard coding values
that are meant to be secret, found a hard
coding hard coded string using the Express
session. So we're actually the secret is right
in here. You don't want to put a secret right
in here, you want to use an environment
variable to go here, we can click on quick
fix. And then the So the suggestion. So here
are some examples of how people fixed it.
This person didn't they change the secret
to just a variable it hasn't been defined
yet. Really, you want to use a, like I said, an
environment variable to fix a problem like this.
So we can actually go through each of
these issues in the code security here.
And then change them one at a time.
So here's one we just talked about.
But the hard coding and we have another
the secret token is right in here.
So that's how sneak is going to help us fix
our issues. So let's see what this one is.
Well disable X powered by header for your Express
app, because it exposes information about the use
framework to potential attackers, and then it
tells you what to use. Consider using helmet
middleware. Some of the vulnerabilities that
we were able to exploit wasn't even in the code
that was written for this app. It was in the
open source dependencies. So let's go to this
open source security section. And one thing
I mentioned is that these are covered coded.
So if it's in red, that means it's basically one
of the worst possible things that could happen,
you know, and then orange is bad, but not quite
as bad. And the yellow is the mildest. Or I
guess gray would be the mildest. So anything
that's red, you definitely want to fix, one of
the issues that we exploited was in handlebars.
So if we fix the hand, if we click handlebars,
it's showing that we're using handlebars four
point 0.14. And suggesting to fix this issue,
we can upgrade to four point 1.0. And then it's
going to go on to show us exactly what the problem
that's happened that happened. So the
problem related to prototype pollution,
and then the unsafe object, recursive merge.
So once I know about this handler thing,
there's a plenty of things I can do
to just kind of upgrade handlebars.
So one thing is that I can go right into my
package json. And you see we still have it here.
HBS. Now I can actually just
change this to four. Point
1.0. Like is recommended. And if
I just close some of these here,
you can see that it's showing right in our
package that JSON file, it's showing all
of these different vulnerabilities. And if I
click here, show the most severe vulnerability.
Now it's saying, for jQuery, I should upgrade
to 3.5 point zero. So I can just type in
3.5 Point Zero to upgrade that. And then we
can go through every single one of these.
And just try to find just try to
find all what what's vulnerable.
But something we may not want to upgrade. But some
things we may want to upgrade just depending on
the severity of the vulnerability and how it's
going to impact your app. Another way you can
go about doing this is using the command line.
So I'll just open up a new terminal down here.
And I don't have sneek installed quite
yet. You just do NPM install. Sneak.
Yeah, latest. So this idea if you have NPM.
And now I can just run sneak test. Oh yeah,
first I have to authenticate sneak sneak off.
Okay, I've authenticate. So
before we authenticated for
VS code. Now we're authenticating for
the command line. And then sneak test.
And this is going to find all this
these things and it's going to so
you can find it right in VS code.
Or we can just use the command line
and see all the red things are the high severity.
So this is kind of nice to find out all the high
severity issues. And these are basically all
dependencies. And it's showing what we need to go
through. So you'd want to go through and
especially all the high severity, things
you want to go through and you want to upgrade to
the version that's not going to have these issues.
And then there's also sneek code test. So before I
was showing all the things that are dependencies,
and now it's showing all the problems in our
actual custom code is part of this project. So
that's just the saying that so the first command
would be stuff from this open source security
panel up here. And then the second command we'd
run was from this code security panel here.
So and we can see that there's three really
important issues that we should try to make
sure we fix. Another cool way to kind of
find vulnerabilities is just through the
web interface. So let's go to the snake
website. I'm going to go to my dashboard.
And it's showing that we can run sneak monitor
here, right in our here. So if I do sneak monitor
and it's showing a website we can go
to I'm going to copy that, copy that.
Okay, now we're in here, we can actually see all
these same issues, but now it's actually easier
to get more information. So this is one of the our
dependencies we have and we can show more detail.
It's going to show how we fix that. And then we
can also actually get more information like CW 29
This is a path traversal issue which is one of
the things we exploited, if you can remember,
if you remember, so we could actually fix that
issue just by upgrading to 4.11 instead of 4.7.
And then if we want, we can also get
more information about the library.
And it goes right to the
NPM website for the library.
So we go down here, and you can see all the
things that are definitely need to get fixed.
So the high priority critical priority, and so
marked, oh, yeah, I saw Mark yet. So this is
another this is one that we exploited. If we just
upgrade to mark zero, point 3.18, then the one
where we were typing in to do items, and we were
able to get JavaScript into there, if we upgrade
this, and that won't be a problem. We can also go
here, where it's suggesting very specific fixes.
So def is saying, definitely upgrade these things.
And it's going to fix all these different issues.
And then if we go here, this is just going to
show all of our dependencies. And you can see
if we click into here, body parser is a dependency
and inside body parser. There's another dependency
this Qs here. And if we click into Qs, well, this
has a high severity issue. So that's something we
definitely want to know about. So this is pretty
great. It's a way to figure out all the security
issues and all the dependencies on your, on
your on your app applications. There's no way to
be able to know all these on your own, you pretty
much need a tool like this, to make sure your your
application isn't using these these dependencies
that have different vulnerabilities like this.
Now, this is outside the scope of this course.
But there's also a way to set up on sneak. So
anytime you push your code to repository, it's
automatically going to run all these tests. And
before you even merge a pull request, it will
show all the security issues that could be in
the pull requests that you're trying to do. And
then you can be required to fix them before you
actually merge that pull request. But now we're
going to talk about containers. Eric, Smalling is
going to teach the next part of this course about
securing containers. He has a ton of experience in
this area and is great at explaining everything.
He'll also give another quick overview of DEV
SEC ops. Everybody, Eric here I am here to talk
to you about containers and security and all the
things that we have to look at now that we're
containerizing our applications a little bit
about myself, so you know where I'm coming from.
I am a software developer for the past 30 years,
give or take. I am a senior developer advocate now
at sneek, a software's security scanning company.
And the last decade or so my career really been
spent more around the CI CD build automation
tests kind of a world and during that I discovered
Docker Docker, I've been using Docker since about
2013. Back in the early early days before we had
any orchestrators or even composed or anything.
Today I am Docker captain and I'm certified
in all three of the Kubernetes certifications
means anything to you. And you can get a hold of
me at that Twitter address or LinkedIn or whatever
all the socials. So what are we going to talk
about today? First of all, we're going to get into
how does security play with DevOps? Is it is it
a vs kind of a thing? Or do they work together?
Next, we'll get into what are the challenges
we face specifically as developers making,
putting our apps in containers and I'm going
to get into a demonstration to show you what
can happen if you don't look out for these kinds
of problems. And we'll get into this you know,
how can you be proactive to avoid the situations
you'll see in a demonstration. And finally,
we'll wrap it all up at the end. So
DevOps is interesting term, it I mean,
literally is just a a melding of development
and operations and everything else in between,
to cooperate to work together and to automate
things together until to work well together.
Unfortunately, it's turned into kind of a buzzword
in our field and it's kind of gone the way agile
did for a while there were consultants will
sell you agile, they'll also sell you DevOps,
or you'll have a DevOps team or DevOps tools. But
really, it's more about the concept of making sure
we're all working together towards fast,
repeatable builds and making sure that everything
is done well together as a team. And often DevOps
is visualized with our software delivery lifecycle
pipelines. The pipeline was kind of popular Back
when the continuous delivery book was written,
and this is a simplistic pipeline, showing here,
yours may look more complicated than that. But
generally you look at ideation to production
from left to right. And it's like an assembly
line. In this diagram, I put our company's old
patched logo on a couple of blocks where we
historically have seen security applied to
our pipelines in production, first of all,
and that's kind of table stakes. We've always had
some kind of security being applied to production,
whether it be firewalling,
or role based access control,
tripwire, tripwires, they all the all the things
that you think of when you think of hardening
for production. We've had security around that.
Well, we also started as the security intern.
And when we started doing pipelines and started
doing continuous delivery, we saw it applied as a
stage as security audits would happen. And usually
they'd be a late stage in that pipeline. Because
oftentimes, it was a manual process. And it was
like a gating kind of a thing where some team
would go in and look at your application
and determine whether or not you have
increased your vulnerabilities or in some in
some way made things less secure. And they would
pull the cord stop the line, and you'd have to go
in and then figure out what it was. And usually
this was after functional testing. So it was like
a late bug in the now you got to put your mind
back into the state of what was I doing when we
worked on that code to move forward since then.
Or it could have been automated, there were
automated tools that been around for a while,
but usually they were so slow, or their licensing
was so onerous that you could only run a few
copies of it, or you could only run it on
certain hardware that your CI pipeline would use.
And so again, these would be late stage
things that cause you to have to stop
and figure out what happened and hopefully
get fixed and quick for the release.
Or unfortunately, often it would be put on
the backlog for a new release, you know,
coming down the line, and you get to production
with known vulnerabilities, which is never good.
As containers started to come in, and we
modernized the way we did security against those
you saw scanning coming in at the registry level.
So you'd push an image to a image registry. And
it might have a built in scanning functionality,
and would grind away for however long it took. And
it would come back often with just a big list of
here's all the CVS have fun with that. Hopefully,
you also had similar things that were able to
be done similar kind of scanning in your CI
as your repo change. So as code is merged into the
mainline, or whatever branching strategy, you use,
something we kick off, do your builds, and one
of the automated tests that would happen would be
that security scan, so you'd build the image might
be able to scan it, or send it off to something or
scan it, you can before it gets to the registry,
that's kind of cool, because now you can break the
build, without having to rely on some kind
of callback from the registry to you know,
break the pipeline after it's already been going.
So that same kind of tool, if it's fast enough,
could actually be applied, pre merge.
So if you're doing Git, for instance,
you have pull requests, often where you have a
short live branch and you come back into your
main or master or whatever you're using. And
you can have one of the automated tests that
happens as part of the validation of that pull
request, be a security scan, again, now that
tool needs to be fast enough to do that. Because
otherwise, people are gonna want to wait a day,
for a pull request to get reviewed, they want to
get it in and be iterative and get it done. But
the Holy Grail of this is really to get that kind
of scanning capability to be so fast and so useful
that a developer will use it day in and day out on
their workstation. He wanted not only to be fast,
but you want the output of it to be actionable,
so that the developer can be proactive,
and not having security and and that
team be an adversarial relationship,
you want to be able to say, hey, issues have come
up, here's the information I have. And then I can
act on this information. Or I can at least go to
the security folks and talk to them intelligently
about what I'm seeing and get, you know,
cooperation there instead of an adversarial role.
And this is where we get the term dev SEC ops. Now
dev SEC ops, in my opinion really isn't a thing.
It is more of a reminder that between Dev and
Ops, security needs to be part of that thing.
Security needs to be invited to our little
DevOps party. Right? They need to be just
integrated, if you will. Now, that talked
about container, you know that they're
challenging. What is it this challenging
about containers? Well, for developers,
you we are increasing our scope of responsibility,
sometimes greatly. This is an area where,
historically, you know, we've dealt with securing
our code and maybe the libraries we pull in.
But containers are writing operating system
level things, things like, what base image
are you using? What is it bringing along? What
distribution? Is that base image built? On? What
packages? Are you installing on top of it? How
are you installing your application? What file
system permissions? Are you using? What user
ID are you using all of that kind of stuff,
which we've known about as developers, but
we might not have really dealt with it much
because the teams that deployed our software
or or built the systems that we deployed to
dealt with it. And so we have a bit of a lack
of expertise around how do you harden a Linux,
Ubuntu versus a CentOS? filesystem. Distribution.
These are things that other people did for us
before. Now, hopefully, we're working with
those teams as we build our Docker files,
and Kubernetes, Yamo and everything else, so
that we're crafting these files correctly.
But I need to know as a developer, if I need
to tweak that file, but I'm doing it right.
And I don't want to have to open a ticket
every time I want to change a Docker file
to my ops team, to say, hey, let's work
together to fix this. I mean, if it's something
complicated, sure, but if I'm just changing,
you know, what package I need for something,
there's got to be a better way. And on top
of all of this, any security practice, you
add to a developer's day to day can't impact their
velocity business has bought into and given us the
ability to do these iterative CD pipelines. All
is because it's all about velocity getting from
ideation to market in front of the customer, as
fast as you can, we're not gonna we don't want to
introduce something that's gonna slow that down.
In fact, they'd probably really like us to faster
if we can. Okay, so let's go back to talking
about what developers know about containers.
We know our applications, you know, when we
write them that we have to pay attention to
the the code itself, the code has to be clean,
you can't be introducing in SQL injection issues,
or whatever, we got to write secure code. And we
know also that our libraries need to be cleaned as
well. But what's new is these Docker files, like
I talked about a, we're dealing with the operating
system issues now. And for instance, looking at
this little screenshot, I know what Python is,
because maybe I'm a Python programmer. And I know
that version three of Python is what I'm on. But
do I know what minor version? This is? Do I
know what Linux distribution is? On top of
do I need to know? What about the packages I'm
installing? And am I doing it correctly? Or am
I installing them in a way that's putting things
on the file system that doesn't need to be there?
All sorts of questions like that come up. And then
of course, we've got infrastructure as code files,
like TerraForm, or cloud formation. And the big
granddaddy of them all would be Kubernetes. And
this is, you know, if you're in an orchestrated
container land, you're dealing with Kubernetes,
most likely nowadays. And this is an API
that changes every three, three times a year
and has a lot of knobs and switches on it.
And it's very easy to make a mistake and
cause a problem that you didn't even know you're
making this mistake. It's enough to get your app
running on these various technologies to make you
hyperventilate, but hardening the app for security
on top of that, well, that's that's that's
asking even more. Okay, so that's enough talking
slides and hypotheticals, let's actually
look at a demonstration of this in action.
So let me stop the scene. Let's say
we're at a company, we have a Java
Enterprise application that we've had running
for years and years. It's our big moneymaker.
But it's in a kind of maintenance phase. We're not
we're not doing active development, or anything,
just bug fixes here and there. And so a
couple years ago, when it was time to,
you know, when containers came on the scene, and
we got access to Kubernetes servers, we decided,
hey, we want to do that. We want to take advantage
of containers, and the standardized packaging and
deployment mechanisms would get with with the
orchestrator. So we lifted and shifted our Java
Tomcat application into a container. We've been
running it that way ever since. So if you look
at this Docker file, this is a multistage
Docker file, which means that there are multiple
different from lines. And for each one of those,
that's a stage. So here we have two of them. We
have the initial one, which builds our application
that's based on the official Maven image from
Docker and the Maven folks. And then we have a
second one that is the official tomcat and from
Apache Tomcat. And anyone who's done Tomcat for
a while, then this is November of 2021 right now,
and this is still eight 521. That's a pretty old
version. But the attitude for a lot of folks is if
it ain't broke, don't fix it. This is the version
we were at in production when we containerized and
we're sticking to it because we didn't works and
we're not making changes that need anything new.
We'll look at, we'll come back to that decision
in a second. The rest of the file is pretty basic.
It's just set up a couple of configuration
files, and then copy artifacts from the build
stage into the main stage of that final image
we produce is Tomcat plus our application and
a couple configs. So let's take a look at this
running. This is the top level sample servlet,
that you see right here. And you can see I pull
this up so that you can see that eight 521 is
definitely the version we're running. Just to
make sure our app is running, I'll pull that
up. And there it is, there's our beautiful To
Do List makes billions of dollars for us or so.
But honestly, the AR app is not what I want to
talk about today. There may be problems in it. But
that's not the discussion. Let me switch hats now
and put on my black hat hacker hat. Now I may be
looking for vulnerable servers to exploit as a
hacker. And in doing that, I'll do my studies. And
I'll see you know, I'm actually looking at tomcats
release notes for vulnerabilities they've fixed.
And you can see there's a bunch of fixes they've
done. And throughout here, we're seeing all sorts
of things. There's denial of service attacks,
there's, oh, gosh, incorrectly documented CGI,
all sorts of stuff. But the one that's interesting
to me are these remote code execution ones.
This means that if I'm able to exploit something
that has one of these vulnerabilities in it,
I might be able to run my own code and somebody
else's server pretty bad. This one we're looking
at right now is fixed in eight 523. That tells
me that anyone on eight pipe 22 or older,
might be vulnerable. And as you saw that,
that company is running eight by 21.
So I could dig into this by go into the
vulnerability databases sneaks vulnerability
database, and very similar mitre, we add
a few extra pieces of information to it.
But what I could dig into this, and I could find
out what is it about Tomcat util that has issues
and what what is it there are the issues and
craft something. But I'm in this first feed,
and I just want to find something quick. And I
see that there's a couple of exploit DB links,
I'm going to click on one. And what this is
his code, this happens to be Python code that
I'm not a huge Python coder. But I could
read this and I can tell Oh, this has got
two methods. It's a proof of concept script that
will check for and exploit against that CVE to
prove whether or not you have it or whether you're
patched. So I'm going to copy that. And I have a
couple of me set this up to do this before the
call. So I'm going to run this shell script,
this is going to basically it's going to take
that Python script, it's going to wrap it in a
container and alias it for me. So it's easy to run
for this demonstration, I'm out. And that's done.
And I'm gonna run the check side of that. And
you can imagine this would be automated. If I
was really going after a bunch of server, I might
have a ton of IPs and ports that I'm ping, ping,
ping, ping, kind of like the old WarGames war
dial are going through looking for vulnerable
and I found one that's my local IP, I'm just
running this locally on a Docker Kubernetes
Docker desktop Kubernetes. This works, any
convenience I want to run it on or any Docker
executable. This is saying it's vulnerable.
And it's stuck a POC JSP onto the server.
So let's jump back over here. And I'm going
to add POC and JSP. And there's a bunch of A's
there. I guarantee that was not there a couple
minutes ago when I showed you the site earlier,
what I've done, and now the A's that's not very
nefarious really, but the ability to take a JSP
and push it to somebody else's
server and have it actually be there.
That's pretty bad. Let's take a look at the other
side of the script, I'm gonna run the phone side,
which will inject a different JSP up there.
Pull that one up, I'm gonna pull the form.
I just ran ENB on a shell basically, but in the
environments that the Tomcat servers running in,
and I can look at this, shrink it a little
bit here. And I can see there's my Java home,
there's a bunch of information and oh, look at
that there's Kubernetes port. That means most
likely, I am running in a Kubernetes server, which
means most likely I'm on a container D or Docker
container. And that's interesting. That's the API
server from the point of view of the pod that I'm
in. So if I wanted to maybe I could start tickling
the control plane of the Kubernetes cluster on it
and seeing if there's anything available
to me. In order to do that I need cube CTL
or be easier if I increase your netus but it'd
be easier and it doesn't look like I have that
I have curl just to curl help. I
do so I've got curl at my disposal.
Now I'm not going to go through in this
demonstration hacking a Kubernetes cluster but I
will show you a couple other things. Oh, I'm root.
So that's nice. That means I can do things like
get in the field Ella ltr et Cie
password. And oops, not LS ltr.
That's not interesting. This is more interesting
Etsy password. Now I'm going to container.
So these users aren't that interesting to
me, but it is I can get out of I can see him,
what can I do? What else can I do? Can
I do this, touch Etsy foo. That works.
The bottom and sure enough, I was able to create
a file in the etc, top level directory on this
container. That's because I'm root. And I have
right access everywhere in this container.
That means I could go into the other web app, the
to do list and I can modify, I can also go change
out things in the JVM itself, I have curl. And
if I have external network access, I can bring
down my own scripts, I can bring my own my own
JVM that has maybe other code baked into it.
But honestly, most most of the time, what's going
to happen now, if I'm root on a white double file
system container, I'm going to sit down and I have
curl and or some other tool, I'm going to download
a script to start crypto mining or something
and use all the CPU I can on this node. So
that's interesting. And hopefully you're in a
real server, the production, intrusion detection
or other alerts are going off now, because I'm
doing things that shouldn't be happening. But
we don't really want to just have a reactionary
posture to this, how could I, as a developer,
have proactively avoided this situation, or dealt
with even unknown vulnerabilities that might be
out there. Let's take a look at that. So I'm going
to go back over here to my Shell kill out of this.
Now, I've already built this image locally,
let's imagine I'm the developer working on
this application at some point, and I'm building
locally to check a bug fix I did or whatever.
And I built my image so that I can run it somewhat
similar to the way it would run in production.
And what I can do though, is before or during
that process, I can go ahead and run I'm going
to run our scanning tool, there's a lot of
different scanning tools out there, I'm going
to run the one that I know the best sneaks into
container test. And the image name is Java goof.
Tag, one. And I'm also going to feed
a metadata into this command, where I
say file is Docker file that lets it know that
this is the Docker file that built that image,
which gives it a little more information about it.
So you can kind of correlate what's in the layers
and what the base image is, and all that kind of
information. So the tool, depending what scanner
use, the way this one's working, is ripping
through all the different layers of the image,
looking at all the packages that are installed
looking at the base image, and then it's
going to go start querying the vulnerability
database on the internet for the very latest
vulnerability lists and come up with compared to
you and letting you know what's in this image,
and what vulnerabilities might be there
for the given versions of everything that's
installed. So as this goes, we see that there
it goes, querying the vulnerability database.
And there we go. So we can go up here and we could
take a look at this list of all the different
things that went wrong or that are could go wrong,
such as this. There's lib curl has a bunch of
vulnerabilities in it saying if I were to upgrade
lib curl to that version, we could get you know,
get past those. But honestly, the more interesting
thing when it deals with dealing with containers,
from my point of view, is down here at the bottom
we're saying hey, you're on base image eight 521
of Tomcat, which we know has 66 critical
and 88 high vulnerabilities 635 total,
if you simply upgraded to a newer version of
Tomcat, and this changes every time I run it
because the vulnerability database is constantly
changing. And saying if you went to this version,
you would drop 222 Total vulnerabilities for
high eight, or sorry for critical and 18 high.
If you are willing to upgrade to a newer version
of Tomcat family into the Tomcat nines, you could
get even less. And then if you were willing to
actually go to a whole different JVM, this is
the Amazon corretto JVM, I do believe you could
actually eliminate all known vulnerabilities.
So at this point, even as a junior developer
who doesn't know squat about Tomcat itself,
and the image, the base image that it's coming
from, I have some good information. I know that,
you know, I've got this many vulnerabilities
and I can have some quick hit fixes. And I can
go to my lead engineer and make my app set person
say hey, here's what I'm seeing. Which of these
makes the most sense to go to and you know,
it's putting them ahead of the the architect
Well, you know, we can't really run on Tomcat nine
yet because we depend on things and eight, five,
so that's not really an option. And I am not ready
to drink the Kool Aid of the new corretto JVM. So
let's at least move to a newer version of Tomcat
in the eight, five family. Let's go to this one.
And we'll take a look at what vulnerabilities are
there and see if we have mitigating concerns. Or
maybe they're they're not, we're not
using that piece of code that's in them.
But I can we can take an educated path towards
repairing vulnerabilities and getting past them.
I'm not going to go through the trouble of
rebuilding this all in showing you I just
guarantee you that if I rebuilt with that, and
tried to do the hack I just did. It won't work
because the vulnerability has been fixed. Let's
talk a little bit about what about vulnerabilities
that we don't know about that the the analysts
have not found zero days things that people are
holding on to for bug bounties, whatever. How
would I deal with that, because the scanners
not going to know that? Well, that brings us to a
conversation about defense in depth. This is good
for both known and unknown vulnerabilities. These
are practices that make it harder for bad actors
to take advantage of your systems. They're
good all the time. So there's three errors,
I'm going to touch on the image, the runtime, and
then some Kubernetes specifics. When it comes to
the image number one thing that we recommend is
to minimize your footprint. And you saw me doing
that a bit when I used a multistage build prior.
That's good, because I'm not including Maven or
the source code of my application in that final
image. But we could minimize it even further.
There's no reason my application should have curl
available. It doesn't use it doesn't need it.
So we should get rid of that. And the best way to
get rid of things like that is to use a smaller
base image first. In the Tomcat world, there are
tags that have the word slim on the end. And this
is true of many base images. And these are built
on in a way that are going to carve it down to
just what you need to run a Tomcat app. Now, it
may not be enough for your application, in which
case, you might have to add a package or two to
it, you'll have to manage that. But generally,
if you're just running a J EE application, you're
not doing anything fancy. The slim versions are a
good choice. There's even further swimming you
can do by going to say the Google Open Source
distro this base images, there's some these have
just like the Java one just has a open JDK JVM.
And nothing else that's not needed to run that
there's no shell, there's no package manager,
none of that. And that that's really secure, it
makes it a little harder to support. If you're not
used to using modern tools, if you're wanting to
exec in, that's not going to happen. Because you
don't have a shell to the executive, right.
You need to understand how layers are built
and the housekeeping around that. So we
couldn't just do a run RM curl, for instance,
to get rid of curl, it would hide it from the
containers filesystem. But savvy hacker that
gets access to the root filesystem through other
means, whether it be a bind mount or something,
can still find those layers because it's just
hidden, it's just marked as deleted, not it's
still in the prior layers. And all of those layers
exist in the container runtimes file system.
So just understand how layers work and
how they're built and how to optimize
for for your running builds, and build
strategies. So multistage is is a strategy for
doing your bills is a good one to use. There's
other tools you can use though. And other
practices, you want to make sure your builds
are repeatable, so that every time you pull
the same commit or source code you get the same
image constructed from and you can do this by
making sure you pick specific tags on images,
you can even put a SHA hash into that image
into that front line and you'll get you're
guaranteed to get that image that had some other
complexities. The people have blogged about the
pros and cons of that, but at least use a specific
image of a version like Tomcat, eight 568, or 71,
or seven, whatever, is better than eight five,
because eight five or eight is a moving target
that will go to in the latest build every time
you you you pull it. There's things like Docker
labels, you could you could use to add metadata
to your image to the image itself that's not used
at runtime, but you use it for fact finding about
what's in an image and there are other tools.
In the Java world there's jib which is a great
tool for building images that doesn't need a
container engine at all to build the image.
There's if you're in the Red Hat environment,
you've got builder and the pod man suite of tools
and Khyber. No, I'm not Carter or sorry, and
Calico and so many names getting mixed up. Then
we also have the secure supply chain. Now entire
conferences are built around this topic nowadays.
But what I want to kind of hit on is the fact
that you need to know where your images come from.
Don't just be deploying anything and Eric Smalling
building an image on his laptop, that image should
never get to a production server because you have
no idea where it came from what was put into it,
you don't have a chain of custody. You don't know
where it's been and how who's touched it along the
way. If you We're interested go look into things
like store and the work towards software bill of
materials and things like that are quite the
topic right now, nowhere near enough time to
talk about that here. When we get to runtime,
this is where the real meat of this comes to,
you can make sure your containers don't run as
root, you can use a user line on on the command
line or in Kubernetes, there's a setting for
that, you can make sure that they're running
as something else. In fact, you can specify
in your Docker file, the default user is x,
do that running as root is dangerous, even though
you're in a container, as you saw I was UID zero,
so I can modify any file in that container. Also,
if somebody heaven forbid, were to bind mount a
host volume into that container, I'm UID. Zero
there too. So I can read and write to host files
that are mounted in. Depending on how its
privileged containers you should never use
unless you're doing something really low level
like Kubernetes monitoring, monitoring software or
writing a CNI, plugin and convenient work
in plugin. Generally, this gives you root
access to devices on the host system. And it's
just a terrible thing to give it just more most
applications. Linux capabilities, these are
features of the Linux kernel system calls
the process can make to do things that are
a little bit escalated, but not quite root.
Ping has Netcat add to it in order to create
ICMP packets, for instance, things like that.
The early Docker teams, and other Container
Engine teams whittled down the good set
a small set of these that most applications should
be able to live with. But business applications
and stuff that a lot of people work on day to
day, don't need any of them, because you're not
doing network, low level stuff and whatnot. So I
would I like to drop all capabilities, and then
just just add back any that I might need.
And there are blogs, written all sorts of
information, just Google for it on how to find
out what capabilities you need to use tools like
s trace, or falcoda. Dig into it. Next we
have the read only root filesystem. This,
when you start a container up the Container Engine
basically takes all the layers of the image,
which are read only compiles those up creates
the virtual filesystem that the process sees.
But then it adds another rewrite layer on top.
And any modifications to the file system are
done in that readwrite. Later, if you change a
file that's in the image, it basically does a
copy on right brings it up to the readwrite
layer and then makes the modification there
any new files get created there as well. You can
however, start this is the default mode, you can
start the container without that readwrite layer,
effectively making it a read only filesystem.
This is very, very good. If you can do it,
if your application can run in that mode,
do it this is makes it immutable, which is
one of the 12 factors which we should all
be aiming for and container land anyway.
If you are app needs to write things to
persist to disk temporarily ephemerally like a
tomcat server. And to use that example, again,
has the work directory and some logs and things.
Use the temp Fs like the Kubernetes Empty Dirt
and mount that path just for that and it will
get it'll get thrown away when the container gets
destroyed. Or mount in external volume and make
sure you set permissions correctly for security
for that. But don't. If you can at all not run in
Read Write mode that can greatly enhance security.
Many of the things you saw me starting to hack at
and talk about, if it was read only, it would have
been very hard for me to do. Bitcoin mining, for
instance, on a read only file system would require
me to be able to pipe like curl down my script
and pipe it it would just be harder to do. And I'd
have no local cache to store things. And it just
it's a great tool to make it harder for the hacker
deploying for unknown sources. This kind of calls
back to what I said before about secure supply
chain. Just make sure you know where your images
come from. Don't be deploying from the internet,
you should probably have your own registry,
whether it's a mirror or your own hosted registry.
Use that. And then finally, if you're running
on Kubernetes, and many of you probably are,
there are tools that Kubernetes Kubernetes adds
that you should take a look at for instance
secrets if you have credentials or other sensitive
information, do not build it into your image.
Do not include it in a flat file that you just,
you know bind route in. Don't use config maps,
though none of those are secure. Secrets can be
secure. They by make sure your cluster admin is
encrypting those secrets at rest because by
default, they're not you have to do that if
you're rolling your own Kubernetes clusters.
But if they are secrets allow you to have your
own role based access control applied them and
it keeps things nice and clean and separate.
Speaking role based access control our back, use
it learn it it can can be a little complicated
and hard to understand at first, but learn the ins
and outs of it and you'll be happy that you did.
security context. This is the specification
for the pods and containers in Kubernetes that
implement a lot of the things I talked about on
the prior slide, things like running with a read
only root filesystem. Running as non, you know,
changing the user you're running as an enforcing
to not be rude. Things like that are in play, are
implemented in Kubernetes, through the security
context, and you should learn about those and
use those network policies are critical. Many
developers get all worked up about network policy,
they think it's very complicated, it's really not,
it's just all about setting rules about what
pods can talk to each other and what can't,
on and on what protocol TCP or UDP
and whatnot, Neal ports and all that,
I'm a big fan of the zero trust pattern, which is
no pods can talk to any pod know any other pod,
except for what I explicitly put an allow
list. So nobody can talk to anybody except
my pods in the front end namespace can talk to
the business tier labeled pods on port 8080 TCP,
so that traffic specifically is allowed. But other
traffic between front ends are Oh isn't. And you
should look into that. If you do that, make sure
you open up egress traffic to your DNS, because
if you don't, then you have no service lookup and
that crashes everything. Pretty much. And finally,
all of these things I'm talking about
enforced that use a tool like Opa,
gatekeeper, or Hive or no, there's also a
pod security policies, which is deprecated,
and going to be replaced by pod security
admission. But that's still in beta as of 123.
If you're watching this from pod security,
admission is out of beta, you know,
by all means use it, but use any kind of these
tools to make sure that deployments that break
the rules, the policies that your organization
uses, can't be deployed. And just just do it.
It's it's it simplifies life. And if you apply it
across all of your environments, then a developer
won't be surprised by the fact that, you know,
in production, I can't deploy as root what,
because I haven't been able to deploy as root
on any of our clusters. So it's just a common
rule set that I've used everywhere. So the key
takeaways from today's talk, the feedback loop
is critical, just like with CI, you know,
came on the scene and became a big buzzword,
letting me know that the build was broken me as
fast as possible that feedback, that fast feedback
loop enables continuous integration. Well, it's
the same thing with security, finding out that I
added security vulnerabilities or somehow
weakened my security posture of my application,
on my own workstation. That's, that's
critical. Having that fast feedback is, is,
is great, because you can fix it now. While it's
still fresh in my mind of what I've just did.
And it didn't get out and you
know, cause impact to other people.
Secondly, the whatever tool you end
up using for scanning and whatnot,
make sure that it allows you to be proactive,
it gives you good information that allows you to
attack now, rather than just scratch your head
and say, Well, I have no idea what this means.
Make sure that it's giving you good, proactive,
actionable information. And then finally,
practice defense in depth. There's always going
to be new vulnerabilities that nobody knows about.
Except that that one hacker that found it and if
you make it harder on the hackers life, they'll
move on to somebody that's an easier talk target.
That's just how it is. So I want to thank you for
watching. Secure your containers. Guys. Thanks.
We've reached the end. You should now have a
better understanding of DevStack ops and be able
to start implementing some new security tools in
your workflow. Check out the description for
additional resources, and thanks for watching.